everybody stand way back golden flames
of life I command you it's like casting
a spell with the
magic flames of life
wait wait what oh serious proof of
evolution yeah okay so I hope you guys
are taking notes let's talk about some
of this
what's up guys we're gonna be talking
about some deception and Christian
entertainment we have our guest today
David from movie night he's got a really
cool program going on we did a show with
him you guys should check that out but
uh yeah have you guys ever watched
anything that was supposedly it's
labeled Christian but when you watch it
there's some questionable things in
there
grew up with a lot of Christian cartoons
I mean Hannah Barbera I don't know if
you can consider that a Christian but
Yogi Bear yeah
the three little kids that would drop
down I don't remember the name of it
yeah yeah
it is okay so the same same producers
made a Bible story where they find this
like uh wall or a door that has all
these lights
archaeologist David and Margo okay
friend Moki oh I know this I have
narrated the uh the show there I watched
every single one as a kid so you know I
have a bird in my heart to create
Christian content that's actually going
to be telling the truth and David does
too you know he works with uh movie
producers and getting these shows in the
movies into the hands of churches that's
going to invite people into the into the
church right yes so casting a wide net
trying to reach people with like good
wholesome movies and I think too often
you know parents might rent something or
or buy something and say oh it's
Christian it's about Noah's Ark here you
go kids and and just set him in front of
it but I've actually done that but I
usually watch the movie as well and I've
seen some things that just don't seem to
line up with the Bible at all so I'm
going to start off with one that I think
a lot of people have seen it's like the
greatest legends and it's actually
introduced by Charleston Heston who
played Moses in the old Ten Commandments
movies and so you know he endorses it
enough to put his face on it and this is
going to be the Genesis story so I've
chopped out parts to make it quicker but
I haven't changed the context this is
exactly how it shows and uh just take
some mental notes because after the clip
we'll talk about the things that just
don't seem to
fly
in the beginning God created
creators was without form God said let
there be light
and there was light
[Music]
aren't you what uh
oh my
I'll decapitate the flower
yeah
violence
[Laughter]
God created the Sun and wait that was
like something in the sun let the waters
bring forth living creatures that was
the same Secret
fish come out of the whales
what I noticed the fish are in fear of
the shark
wait wait what
oh serious proof of evolution yep
there's a desert Wasteland and Garden of
Eden
I've been here absolutely not
that's a desert
this dust will do the job perfectly
what's that everybody stand way back
golden flames of life I command you
touch down upon this Dusty desert and
warm the sleeping man who Slumbers like
a baby in a cloud of dust it's like
casting a spell with the
magic flames of life
foreign
to God forming it with his hands
a man is made in my image
the image of a fiery eye exactly
are you anyway I am God the Creator I
made the earth and the whole universe
if you need a mystery he will never die
[Music]
not until I say so and until then his
babies and the Flaming sword the guard
history day and night baby angels are
guarding the Tree of Life wait a second
though you must leave the garden so
you've obviously cut out the okay
yeah yeah
right
when did rain come on oh wait the
flowers the Angel's tears tears okay and
then the flood
okay so I hope you guys are taking notes
let's talk about some of this
I'm crying I'm I'm laughing so hard was
this made in the 70s no it's like the
90s 90s yeah oh my Charleston Heston is
usually at a desk talking he's a real
life person and he's talking uh
introducing each of these cartoons and
I've watched a lot of the other ones and
they seem to be pretty true I mean of
course I don't want to Hound this thing
so much like you can't have any kind of
creative Liberty to tell the story
um you know like talking animals and
stuff I'm not gonna like Hound on that
but they all see a night Sun Worship in
God yes like a little bit problematic
exactly yeah and and you wonder like if
the people that really either wrote this
maybe were just like Hey Nobody's doing
anything with Christianity over here and
they don't know much about it so they're
just kind of blending all these sort of
half-baked ideas together it was the
only Animation Studio they could find
yeah
you know it was in Chinese and like
there's this Lost in Translation
somewhere along the that that is
actually a harder one to find like I've
I've looked up these cartoons and that
specific one with the Arabic or whatever
translation is like the only one that
exists I'm I'm thinking they got a lot
of backlash from this yeah they're
scrubbing yeah yeah but that's pretty
blended with some pretty bad ideas
Evolution was in there okay can we can
we label those out just so we know what
what those bad ideas yeah like the fish
becoming uh animals on on Earth at first
the fish were running from the sharks
who wanted to eat them yeah in the
Garden of Eden and there's like a desert
you know that was not necessarily like
you know a lush environment yeah Garden
of Eden was a perfect place there was no
desert and yet these crows are there
talking about it and then how was Adam
made yeah it's just a whirlwind yeah
Adam was made from the from the earth
with the hand of God it says he formed
him out of the Dust of the earth and the
clay and everything
you know and like I said I don't want to
like nitpick too much but when you got
all this together man what is a kid
walking away with for one there was some
there's scenes that made God not really
seem too friendly too
after they ate the fruit and they went
to go eat he was like no oh not now and
then the baby angels are guarding the
tree and then the angels are crying the
what about the the rain the rain didn't
happen until after the flood yeah
they're not Angel tears God's not
bowling up there to cause thunder
I don't think there was bowling but what
else can we get to there was there was
no rain or clouds that I know of in the
Bible before the ark and so yeah I just
when I see this kind of stuff you know I
think we should train up a child in a
way they should go we should teach them
the truth we need to worship God in
spirit and Truth and if we're raising
kids on these
false ideas like this you know what is
that going to do to a kid all right and
a picture's worth a thousand words so I
think when you're branding you know even
a cartoon can really plant an idea in
someone's mind that isn't necessarily
true and I mean you know I'm sure we're
going to get into other other cartoons
that do this similar thing but I mean
it's impactful to a kid I think the two
most problematic were that God's an
All-Seeing Eye assemble the sun and the
evolution yeah Evolution was big that
can be used uh as
an evolutionist teacher can show you
yeah even the Christians believe the
fish became Lions exactly they even had
the same Stripes yes exactly
so um this I I did a screenshot of the
end the script was uh the script
consultant was a reverend so it's an
email a female oh a female Reverend yeah
interesting I didn't even notice that
female Reverend Kathleen I mean it could
be uh someone that uh he that thought he
was a she maybe this is maybe and Dr
Daniel Lee Kaplan so I didn't look these
people up or anything but I see that
it's a reverend and a you know someone
that has it could have been Daniella one
time yeah
you know what I mean so it's not just
like some secular person that was like
hey let's make a cartoon about the myth
of the Bible which that does happen such
as the Noah movie and things like that
where those people don't even claim to
be Christian in any kind of way but
they're fighting pirates on that is that
the same one you're talking about yeah
because it was based on a on a um a
comic book series called Noah and it was
like you know just sort of this weird
take of that but it definitely like a
little bit of a crossover and I think
that's why people felt like they was
telling the Christian story but yeah
there was definitely evolution in the
Noah movie they showed a time lapse of
let's talk about that for a second why
can't God use Evolution because when I
first became a Christian I had been fed
these ideas and I was like well maybe
God used Evolution but if God created
the Earth in six days
and he created man he didn't create a
one-celled amoeba and let it turn into
man he created man he formed man from
the dust of the ground on day six and
you could say well the Bible says that a
days is a thousand years well
the plant life was created the day
before the Sun so if that's plant those
plants are living a thousand years
got bigger problems here yeah so that's
a good point yeah so you can't God did
not use Evolution plus Evolution
requires death it's always a survival of
the fittest and uh you know it's not
just one cell to me but evolves over
time it's it's reproduction and causes
uh mutations and and different changes
who can get to the female first and uh
and who can survive and who is the best
fit to survive yeah and that's not
really how God invented things right and
when things to propagate like that and I
think it also adds a Mystique to the
Bible if you're you know the Bible says
you know in six literal days this was
created and then it's like well you know
that's to be interpreted and however you
see it and then all of a sudden you're
adding all this extra kind of ideas in
there then it's like not as linear as
the Bible describes it right because it
says the morning and the evening was the
sixth day or whatever it specifically
says that so A morning evening doesn't
usually take a thousand years
uh this one was called All Creatures big
and small it actually has multiple
titles I've seen it called two by two
I've seen it called I think it was
called The Arc I've seen it called
um Noah is missing oops Noah is missing
um so there's a couple different names
for this I'm not sure why that is but
anyway this is common sense uh media and
this is what we just watched no this is
another one okay so this is kind of like
the the story of Noah's Ark from the
perspective of the animals
and it says ages seven and up and you
know it's basically saying it's it's the
story of Noah's Ark but let's look at
the trailer
it's the end of the world listen there's
a flood coming finny we'll drown if we
don't leave but all animals shall be
saved
all animals are welcome on
[Applause]
as long as you're onto his list
well almost all
I'm sorry Finney we're not on the list
ah I knew they'd turn us away
is that like some Amalgamated
Noah's Ark is their only salvation
you really think this is gonna work
we'll get on the ark
you'll see this isn't my husband you're
not the only ones who want a board this
is Mr and Mrs group see told you we'd
get on the ark
this isn't the ark children
[Music]
what children
where's my daughter Finney
[Music]
the untold story but my son
he's all I have of the animals that
didn't get on the ark
I don't think anyone will miss a little
mysterian
foreign
I mean the animation is not bad
of legendary proportions yeah someone
put some money into it yeah
[Music]
you just wonder did the guy right in the
check read the script yeah solid
[Music]
I like that gag
yeah oops Noah's is gone
so would you European
it looked I don't know it got released
in a lot of different places but
one thing I noticed was
okay so this is like some weird animal
that nobody can identify and they said
that all animals are welcome on the ark
if you're on Noah's list and so the main
character is the son and his dad and and
they're not on the list apparently
but you I you want to you want those
people to be on the ark because you you
grow to love these characters so
you know I don't know there's nothing
really biblical that says that maybe
there were certain animals that God
didn't bring on the ark but
maybe there were some kind of crazy
amalgamations that God didn't want on
the ark I'm not sure I'm just putting
that out there but if that were the case
then you wouldn't want them to be on the
ark yet the whole object of this is you
want them to get on the ark right I
think it says two of each kind yeah yeah
so not every breed of dog and bird or
dog right yeah raccoon seven of the
clean I think it was two of each kind
and then there was seven of each clean
but but what what I think is really I
think is interesting about this is it
portrays the animals as as human
thinking beings that want to be saved
and can't be saved because they're not
on the list and they don't get they
don't Chosen and so it leads you to
think that God is a a terrible God that
doesn't get to be you know doesn't
doesn't allow things to happen doesn't
allow people we find that in the Bible
the people that didn't want to be on the
ark they don't want to be on the ark the
people that did want to be in the ark
they get to be on the right yeah Free
Will and so that door was open for 120
years yeah and they didn't want on there
until the rain started coming uh another
thing that's interesting this could be a
nitpicky thing but it's the sun it's the
father and the son that are trying to
get on the ark if you're taking two of
every animal on the ark where's your mom
yeah you don't want a father and a son
because they're not going to be a
procreate
that that's what I did I was like where
is it going but they use deception you
know to try and and get on there and so
it's like almost kind of validating you
know using deception
they just got better graphics this time
that's right so uh here's another one
Noah's Ark it seems to be like that that
is like the it's a great fun story right
adventurous story potentially exactly so
it gets made a lot
um animations and things like that this
one's called Noah's Ark and it's on this
website I screenshot this so you can see
it's from shout kids it's specifically
for kids it is for children
um and it's called Noah's Ark it's rated
G or PG I've seen both I actually read
that there was two different versions of
this that were released uh
a PG which is Parental Guidance and then
a g version but it is for kids because
it says shout kids there yeah
um and here's a scene from the movie
um
[Music]
rain I want to live that's what the
animals that's what the animals
my appetite is growing and my teeth are
very sharp I will survive I will survive
hey hey
so I I think she's a panther and I'm not
sure but her name is panty
k-a-n-t-y oh that's short and an
abbreviation and she's obviously very
seductive I don't know just very
inappropriate I think taking a story
like this and
yeah do you think any of the animals
that Noah brought on the ark were trying
to eat each other and
I mean it was a supernatural act that
they even lined up two by two and got on
the ark I think God could keep him from
killing him yeah which was really a
story that was illustrating the point of
like look even the animals would listen
to God and look at the people who have
the you know top of the food chain
they're they're defiant and and
ultimately gonna you know do whatever
they want yeah so it was kind of a way
that that I think
was a illustration to the universe
probably like look how defiant man's
heart can be yeah I took some
screenshots of um
reviews on this and I forgot to add them
in here but basically there was people
who bought this because they wanted to
see this scene apparently this scene
kind of went viral on the internet and
so people started buying this movie
because for the panty song
and uh yeah and when they got it they
were disappointed that it wasn't in
there so some were disappointed that it
was in there because that's why they
wanted it others parents were
angry that it was in there
so they sold an edited version yeah a g
version and a PG version and this so
this is the PG content yes and this was
omitted from certain versions of it but
there was the reviews were so mixed
there was people there like oh a great
film for children and the other is like
this is not for children even
non-christians were saying this is not a
Christian or children's film and then
there's Christians are like oh it's
great for the kids and it's like
and it just shows you like where's our
discernment you know yeah if even a
non-Christian is saying this is not for
kids and it's not a Christian
but yeah you got Christians saying oh
yeah it's great
are they are they really not paying
attention or even worse are they seeing
it and still don't have discernment yeah
I think over time when you keep exposing
yourself to non-biblical ideas I think
when you really get to the brass tacks
of needing to understand those spiritual
Concepts it's all mixed around yeah and
very difficult probably to Bubble truth
to the surface you know and you become
desensitized by sexual themes like
you're so used to seeing it it's like oh
no big deal I mean yeah she's shaped
like a woman that's a but there are
things in happening there are movements
happening that you just shouldn't
include in a children's cartoon I think
it reminds me of uh what's that what's
that Jessica Rabbit yeah Roger Rabbit
yeah yeah that's what it looks like
exactly
so this is one recently I came across
you can see this is on Vision video
um they are a channel that uploads a lot
of Christian content maybe some are just
family friendly but
they have a lot of Christian content on
there me and my daughter we're always
trying to look for new things because we
watch a lot of the same Bible cartoons
and things like that so when I saw this
I kind of got excited I was like oh cool
the art style looks neat and different
and uh when I watched it I couldn't even
finish it and my daughter agreed and she
was like yeah let's turn this and
finally
humans
and on the seventh day God rested
okay that's great
oh
huh
uh-huh
oh and so Adam was put in charge of the
garden and it was his to enjoy
he was very lonely
Adam asked the Lord why when all the
animals had partners he did not
[Music]
he's lonely the Lord heard Adam's lament
and responded putting him into a deep
sleep
the Lord extracted a rib from Adam's
chest
from the rib
God made
woman
as the trip wore on tempers grew short
and Noah found himself thrust into the
role of mediator
a role for which he was at best
socially disadvantaged
thank you
after 40 days
God remembered Noah
and the rain stopped
after 150 days
the water subsided
[Music]
as Noah said that on dry land and now
gave Noah permission to eat everything
that lives and moves not just the plants
and fruits that were given to Adam oh
boy Noah's sacrifice pleased
As Time passed Noah found himself laying
in the fields all day staring at the sky
utterly and completely alone a question
gnawing at him until one day he looked
up and asked Lord
you are called compassionate
so why weren't you more forgiving of
your creation
I don't remember that but there was no
reply what in that silence Noah turned
the question onto himself it's it's hard
to imagine that people would even write
this kind of Twisted dialogue
there's
there's no evidence in this cartoon that
God is even a loving being he's just
lazy and he sleeps up there and he's
just controlling stuff and it's like oh
my alarm clock went off and okay we'll
stop them from this terrible experience
you forgot about the rain yeah oh oh
yeah it's raining I killed everyone yeah
and it as subtle as that is I mean it's
just it's just like look at what a jab
it is at God constantly it's just like a
you know he's an idiot and you know well
speaking of it it said that God made
Adam in His image and he's like oh yeah
yeah he's like a caveman dude Adam was a
genius yeah yeah that's a good point he
used 100 of his brain he was yeah he
didn't name him quite a few animals yeah
and come up with the language somehow
and totally made him look like a doofus
and then it was like uh he cried because
he wanted a mate and God goes
okay they're being comical we pushed him
to sleep but it's just like
dude the way they portrayed God is a
cloud with a finger and at some point in
this cartoon it shows the cloud with
legs walking around on earth like
it's just I don't know man it's
just demoralizing or something you know
I wonder what these people would be like
if they actually could go up and meet
God and present him with this script
there you go I want to make it this way
I want to make this about you how do you
feel about that God like you wouldn't do
it just don't even think about that I
think it would they would honestly say
uh there is no God I don't have to worry
about that yeah because I can't imagine
someone that really truly believes in
the stories in the Bible making
something like that yeah dude I I
actually made comments on this saying I
can't believe you guys uploaded this and
and I saw responses like why and it's
just like this is like the Beavis and
butt head of the Bible right
um
and God the cloud is asleep while Noah
is out there and you know it's just like
yeah and then again we show the animals
you know things were getting tense and
the animals are going crazy and it's
like where was that in the Bible and
then him laying it looking at the sky
like
uh you you're supposed to be
compassionate but how come you didn't
have more compassion on the world I like
creative Liberties but at the same point
you gotta maintain the character of God
because that's the whole Bible the whole
Bible is focused on the character of God
yeah perfectly said I agree I I think
hey a lot of things that Jesus taught
most everything that Jesus taught was a
parable he believed in telling stories
to tell a moral to tell a truth
but it didn't change the character of
God it didn't twist the character of God
and so you know when you're trying to
get kids attention and you're trying to
tell a story in an entertaining way
I don't think it's necessarily like
blasphemy to make the animals talk or
something like that but to show God you
know bashing his head and falling asleep
and yeah just really it does twist the
character of God so did you know that
the Berenstain Bears are Christian
company I didn't know that I did know
that yeah so they have Berenstain Bearer
Bibles and they talk about like the
Golden Rule treat others as you want to
be treated and and they actually have a
Berenstain Bear Bible so I was pretty
surprised when I saw this opening scene
of uh
big Paul supposed to be like the Bigfoot
um just I'll let you guys be the judge
this is The Berenstein Bear right there
this cartoon yeah hey Molly
breeding the Harvest honeycomb
honeycomb
combed honeycomb trip
what lies ahead
I handsome stranger money a trip
quizly Grump Grizzly growl what holdeth
the future
tell me honeycomb tell me now
[Music]
the legend
the legend of big ball what in the
Witchcraft yeah that's what I'm talking
about dude this is straight divination
what they're doing
um this is one form of it there's
different forms of
divination like scrying where you look
at a shiny surface whether that be a
crystal ball or a bowl of water or a
mirror or this surface here
interestingly enough but yeah scrying is
when you look at a shiny surface and
you're asking the Spheres to show you
the future you can also do it in the
form of dropping wax into water and
seeing what the shape turns out to be
like like oh uh
what profession will I have and you drop
in if it looks like a broom well you're
going to be a janitor or something I
think this really speaks to the amount
of Witchcraft that is probably pervasive
in our culture you know it's like if
it's really one of the fastest growing
um you know religions and you see it on
TV constantly I mean you think of all
the generations of people that have had
these kind of like ideas planted in
their minds and then they go to make
something like this and they're just
pulling from all the creative stuff that
they've they've been exposed to in their
life and I mean this is really blending
witchcraft right so I have a verse here
in Deuteronomy 18 10 it says there shall
not be found among you anyone that
maketh his son or his daughter to pass
through the fire or that uses divination
which is exactly what we saw or an
observer of times or an enchanter or a
witch or a charmer or a consulter with
familiar spirits or a wizard or
necromancer for all that do these things
are an Abomination unto the Lord and
because of these Abominations the Lord
thy God doth Drive thee from before thee
so what she was doing was divination
communicating with familiar spirits
and I'm just really surprised that that
made it in but like you said it's so
pervasive in our culture God doth Drive
thee out from before thee so yeah I mean
I was I was surprised to see Divination
in the Berenstain Bears but like you
said it's so pervasive in our culture I
only think people realize what's
considered witchcraft you know I I'll
admit I was the same way when I first
became a Christian in my adulthood uh I
even played somebody did my tarot and I
was like you know I didn't really
realize how deep that was I thought it
was kind of like a parlor trick or
whatever and I was really mind blown at
how accurate it was which kind of woke
me up to what was going on but you know
like eight balls and things like that I
think we just kind of think oh it's just
like a little
novelty yeah novelty thing you know you
don't think much about it so many people
put hope in that stuff yeah they say
You're really serious I had some friends
that took that stuff serious right I eat
Chinese a lot and you break up with a
fortune cookie I'm not like oh it means
something I just kind of laugh it off
um but some people do live by those
things astrology and all that kind of
stuff
um this was a movie another showed up as
a Christian movie
and tell me if you hear anything or tell
me what you think is alarming about this
scene right here
I could still smell you Wendy's those
old things
you should throw them away
ever
I thought you were going to clean out
this little place
[Music]
why don't you get some help I've been
thinking about it
you know what next week is
of course
it's our anniversary it's the only date
I care to remember
is holding you
we'll be together again
no someday
necromancy okay and who who made this
one uh I don't know it's like it's on a
like a Christian site website though
it's it's promoted as like a Christian
movie I actually watched it before I
knew what was going to be in there and
uh she's trying to witness to her
daughter yeah her daughter's in a bad
place and her comes to live with the
grandma and the grandma's trying to you
know show Christ to her and stuff but
yeah communication with the dead I mean
it's a strictly forbidden in the Bible
yeah it says regard not them that have a
familiar Spirit she was talking to
somebody that was familiar to her her
husband neither seek after Wizards to be
defiled by them I am the Lord your God
this is necromancy
and so yeah I mean we should be
really
making sure that what we're watching is
is the truth
well as a distributor you can't trust
the content creator because
they make each scene and they get under
pressure to make things work out and
they always Overlook stuff yeah
um
there's a story I heard from when
Mark and roma were doing uh
The Bible series Bible series and I
don't think I don't remember if it was
in The Bible series or the Son of God
movie but they had the Loaves and Fishes
confused the amount yeah right in the I
think there's two different instances in
the Bible too so well they had it they
had they were rushed running and gunning
trying to produce something that they're
just someone just said oh there's the
the amount of loves and Fishes were
opposite right so they had to go and
like change it all uh but someone had to
go through and like filter that and say
you know that that has to be fixed yeah
yeah
um and many times on low budget
production stuff they're getting people
that just say hey I'm a writer I'll
write for you like all right you can
write and nobody really stops to correct
it all so we get movies sent to us all
the time and I sit there and watch it
and like
no can't have that scene wow and then
and then a big problem is the the
creative person that came up with the
idea they don't want any of their ideas
removed out of the right content so if
you like remove one scene they say it
ruins the whole thing when I think it
makes it enhances it because there's no
confusion behind it yeah so when you see
a lot of this stuff I look at it if
someone just didn't filter it properly
and they just said hurry up let's get it
done investors got to get his payback
and we want to get on to the next
project and they just overlooked it they
put it out there and nobody filtered it
I see it as a creative way to engage the
audience and not necessarily something
that's not biblical yeah I see what
you're saying yeah that's that's wow
that's wild and there's so many
perspectives on what is biblical and
what is not yeah that too and that's
that like that plagues the entertainment
industry I see stuff that someone will
say oh that's biblical and I'm like well
we're not going to show it
that's good that's good that you filter
through everything and you don't just
put stuff out there because that shows
that you care about the quality and the
and the truth not just numbers or money
or whatever yeah yeah well I mean with
movie night we're putting movies in
churches that's a huge huge huge
responsibility yeah I didn't realize how
big your responsibility was until I
started these pastors are like yeah you
can take over my screen I'm like oh you
better make sure you know and we have a
Rob Schneider movie yeah you want to
talk about risk all right brand wrist
so John 4 24 says that God is a spirit
and they that worship Him must worship
Him in spirit and in truth I hear a lot
of times that people are just like you
know I love God I worship him but you
break out the Bible and have a Bible
study they don't even care like I've
literally had people say
um you know I just I do whatever the
Holy Spirit leads me to do like they're
following the guiding of whatever
they're hearing I'm not saying that God
can't talk to you I know he can he spoke
to me but when you have to test every
Spirit according to the word of God and
for people to say like oh well that was
written for them and
God's never he's he doesn't change for
one he's not a respecter of persons for
another so if he wrote something for
them and it seems like that's what I see
a lot is like oh well that was written
for the Jews oh that's written for the
future tribulation people well what part
of the Bible is for us yeah
it really seems like a lot of the
Christians today don't even think that
any of the bible really applies to us if
I believe his name
and I worship him then I'm good to go
and I just follow the leading of the
Holy Spirit well I've seen that spirit
that is called the Holy Spirit lead into
some very
uh
tricky places yeah you test them
according to what the Bible says so the
Bible is the ultimate test of what is
truth and so I think that's that's
dangerous because you're also going to
think that you're you're hearing voices
but the voices might be your own
thoughts or they might be something else
that you don't necessarily need to beat
this thing to yeah I mean we we get this
character of Satan he's like scary with
red horns and a pitchfork but he's an
angel of Light man he can he is so
deceptive that he convinced Eve to eat
the fruit when God told him not to you
know he's very deceptive and he's very
cunning he knows the the Bible probably
better than any of us for sure you know
if you don't know the Bible he's already
got one yeah constantly and so all of
this kind of you know mixing of ideas
and theology that's not really
biblically sound I think it just inches
people one step further away from the
truth the truth is found in the word of
God and people have to know what the
Bible is if if they don't know or
they're not reading it then this sounds
funny or plausible or you know it's like
you don't quite you don't quite have a
barometer and I think that that this is
clearly people writing this you know
they don't know they don't know they
don't read the Bible they don't have an
idea
um of what exactly the Bible says and so
yeah I believe the final deception is
going to be so close to the truth that
it's going to deceive Millions yeah
absolutely of Christians of people who
believe but because they weren't the
worship of human spirit and in truth
they're going to fall for the signs the
Miracles it's going to look good you
know we we see some of these movies
where they make the Antichrist look like
oh I want to kill all the Christians but
I don't really think that's what the
Bible shows I think the Bible shows that
there's going to be a one world religion
of peace and safety and it's going to
look great it's going to look like
Revival it's gonna suck a lot of people
in Revelation 13 actually talks about
that talks about the um talks about how
there's going to be a worship problem
and the Bible actually says it twice in
that chapter it says Those Who worship
the Beast those who worship I mean we
get so caught up I think many Christians
do on what is the mark of the beast or
what is this let's interpret what this
stuff is well the Bible explicitly says
that this this is about worship and what
does it say in Isaiah 14 12 it says that
Satan loves to be worshiped he wants to
be as God sitting on his throne so it's
all going to come down to what is
worship and who are you worshiping and I
think that's what we need to focus on
rather than uh the other things amen
Proverbs 22 6 says to train up a child
and the way he should go and when he is
old he will not depart from it so I
think it's really important what we sit
our children in front of you know yeah
it might be a Christian movie it might
be a Christian story at least but it
might not have all the correct details
in there that could Lead You astray such
as the evolution aspect
and it also teaches kids that they can
fudge the word when they need to to make
things work oh yeah yeah it shows
compromise you can't show your kids to
compromise in any capacity amen I love
that first John 4 1 says beloved believe
not every Spirit but try or test the
spirits whether they are of God because
many false prophets are gone out into
the world we can literally say that
these movies are like a false prophet
they're showing you their truth of the
Bible and you have to test that you have
to put it to the test does this line up
with the Bible or not and I think that's
really important for us to do Luke 21 8
says and he said take heed that ye not
be deceived for many shall come in my
name saying I am Christ and the time
draweth near go ye not there to after
them
I'm gonna say two they're born therefore
go ye not therefore after them so again
these things are coming in the name of
Christianity the name of Christ This is
a Christian cartoon but he says be not
deceived that many are going to come in
his name but the truth is truth you
can't compromise on truth and you have
to make sure that it really does line up
we we talk about this uh example a lot
Bankers they don't study the counterfeit
bill they mess with real money all day
long when a counterfeit comes to them
they could have their eyes closed and
identify it nope that's fake I feel
money all day long they study the truth
in order to identify the counterfeit not
the other way around you don't study the
counterfeit all day long so that you can
somehow identify the truth
First Corinthians 15 33 says be not
deceived evil Communications corrupt
good manners so I believe this is evil
communication when you're twisting the
word of God and it will corrupt you
and one of the main things the first
thing that Jesus said when they said
what will be the sign of your coming
they said let no man deceive you it's
all about deception the last days is
going to be full of deception yeah so we
have to be so careful and that's why I
wanted to to show this just to show that
there's a lot of deception out there
even in the Christian world you can't
just trust it because it's got a
Christian stamp on it that's like uh
there's some things that just shouldn't
even have Christianity labeled on it and
we've talked about that before Christian
tarot cards call them Angel cards
Christian Ouija boards
um this is not one of those yeah I mean
this is where our discernment has fallen
to where we're accepting these types of
things so um
that's right read your Bible
and pray every day that's right so David
we really appreciate you being a guest
on the show I really appreciated your
input since you're messing with a lot of
the movies and stuff and you're really
trying to do something that I think is
really cool how you're trying to reach
the world how do you get somebody that's
never going to step foot into a church
into the church and you just
say hey we got a cool wholesome move you
want to come watch it and once once
they're in there then you can do what
the role of a Christian Is Love on them
and ask them hey you know if I invite
them to church I love it yeah if anyone
sees our brand we're not trying to force
you to be Christian we just want you to
come hang out with us we're all
Christians here we don't bite we love
you movies are free for anybody wants to
attend a church and
um I do I do hope that anyone that does
attend these events somehow find God in
some way in your life and get attached
to them as I did and let them change
your life and let them direct your steps
to a place in this world and after this
world is over that you'll be very very
satisfied with and I pray that everybody
out there has it on Earth as it is in
heaven because it is a beautiful
lifestyle to be walking with God on a
daily basis so thank you very much I
appreciate you guys the show I really
enjoy it the studio is great it's a
blessing to us our team you know thank
you thank you very much hey man if you
guys want to hear the rest of his story
we have a video on that so we hope you
guys check it out if you were blessed by
this if you think that this is important
then we just hope that you share it with
everybody and we just really that's our
call to you getting God's word study the
truth so that you can not be deceived
and so you can identify the counterfeit
and not fall for Satan's tricks because
he is cunning he's subtle and he's a
master deceiver we love you we thank you
guys don't forget to give this video a
simple free thumbs up it really helps
get this video out in the algorithm and
if you're not a subscriber hit subscribe
and we cannot do this without our
supporters so we just thank you patreon
donors yes we love you and we really
couldn't do this without you if you guys
want to support this ministry you can do
so through patreon or go to
littlelightstudios.tv towards slash
donate
and you can do it there we love you
we'll see you guys next time
[Music]
foreign
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]